[Musique]
pour moi ma vraie naissance c'est 2006
en comment dire en survivant de cette
accident je me lance des défis que je
m'étais jamais lancé avant je m'autorise
à être peintre je m'autorisais pas avant
je vais avoir un bébé enfin et les
protèes tu en as pas parce que tu peux
pas en mettre ben je veux pas en mettre
parce que je préfère être par terre
parce que Mo je cours plus vite et puis
ben je joue plus avec les autres tandis
qu' les prothèses et ben va courir j'
voir un PS et tout ça cé important
machin et en fait ma thérapie cétait le
sport
quoi c'est ce qui me me fait avancer
donc on
continue l'évidence c'est sur public
SNA